boys today is a very special day today
we're dusting off some videos that quite
frankly should have been erased and
forgotten but today are being dredged
back up from the depths why
because quite frankly i think some
people need to see them yes they suck
yes we will cringe but i think it's
important let me explain why listen
when i grew up i always wanted to be
able to sing yes
yes
i'm not gonna do it don't worry thank
you for sparing me but everyone in my
family told me look don't bother you're
not good you're not talented and to be
fair it was true so i never practiced
until in college i saw a video of this
small time artist may have never heard
of him ed sheeran okay and he showed the
first time he had sang before and the
results shocked
[Music]
dear me no yeah that's right and i know
uh you know most people laugh at this
but for me it was a revelation okay the
understanding that people don't just
walk out of the womb doing the michael
jackson hip thrust and singing like an
angel it actually really encouraged me
and ever since then i've been sort of
shameless about singing everywhere and
practicing because i just realized that
sucking and being bad is part of the
process they were all beginners at some
point and that's the real way to think
about it you aren't bad at something you
are a beginner you are inexperienced it
is a growth verse fixed mindset and so
today i want to help contribute to that
understanding because today we're going
to be looking at
arguably my only skill in life which is
making videos and i'm gonna show you
where i started now i'm not at sharon
and i know this isn't a late show not
doing make-a-wish yet thankfully but
hopefully we can give you guys the same
lesson okay
you don't need to be steven spielberg to
understand that we've gotten better so i
hope this is an uplifting message for
you guys let me set the stage for you
where we're at and where it all began
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla and i haven't always been
in the 10 million dollar studio guys
when all this started the dream it all
started in a small bedroom in college
station taxes guys going to school for
chemical engineering i hated it okay my
big dream was not to do what i did in
school
okay and so in my head guys at the time
i was thinking
i'm gonna go be
a youtuber right i'm gonna go do what
fred the youtube star did so
i in college started making youtube
videos and here's the first one that i
ever did let's watch
and get ready to cringe i know i will
now guys i just want to note here that i
did get a glass of wine for this because
this is going to be tough already i'm
offended by the camera angle okay yes
that is a uh that is what we'd call a
very artistic
choice if we're being very charitable
there's me i thought it was gonna be a
piano star that's right i'm a mediocre
pianist on the best day but i was sure
that i was going to be
entertaining the masses with my mad
skills so let's watch a little bit now
don't get excited not too many camera
angles here
can we get some volume here
that's it you know it's not bad i mean
i'm not listen my point is not that it's
bad honestly we can play it as
background music as i give you
commentary for what i think for this you
can see me
trying okay youtube's a video platform
though it's a personality platform what
am i doing
my face isn't on screen
my uh bird like wrists very skinny
wrists
um they're right there i don't know what
what's going on i feel like like i'm
getting vertigo watching the video so
we're just gonna go ahead and move past
this now this was back in 2014 guys it's
taken me
seven years okay to go from this
to this all right wait i don't know if
that's that impressive actually
maybe we should scrap this idea guys not
that impressive no i'm just kidding
let's just move on now let's fast
forward a bit because i don't want to
bore you guys it's a lot of me just not
understanding how stuff works so this is
me
three years later okay almost exactly
three years later still trying the piano
thing bold move okay
still looking like a young stud okay not
no beard yet those gurus haven't
grounded me down into a bulb uh let's
watch a little bit of this
so you can see my camera framing has
improved
you know playing still okay you know
we're all right we're not oscar peterson
but uh that's okay i still not by the
way
okay so i'm doing some weird head
gyrating that's how you know that i'm in
the mood okay
um the point is what are we doing here
okay this isn't spotify this is youtube
uh who's this guy why should we care i
have no on camera anything yet i haven't
figured it out okay at some point i
realize i'm not the greatest piano
player in the world so what do i really
have to offer it can't just be piano and
that's smoldering
smirk okay gotta be something else
so
i make a shift now this is this was big
for me okay i'm gonna walk you guys
through and i hope as you're watching
you are collectively going oh my gosh it
took him three years to realize that
he
he wasn't going to um wow people with
solo piano on youtube when there's
literally the greatest piano players in
the world on youtube it took you three
years to figure that out yes it did okay
i hope that gives you some context so
now
okay this is the video
guys
this is me finally figuring it out i
think i just graduated college actually
right here i'm realizing the time is now
okay let's watch gosh i look so young uh
so there are a lot of big changes coming
to this channel
and uh so let's get on with it so
firstly i just started college which is
super cool because it frees me up a lot
to do more things with the channel and
uh it's also super weird because my life
is so why is my voice so high pitched i
don't i'm not here to roast my i'm sorry
i'm sorry go ahead
steven from the past
keep going sort of been planned out to
this point now there's just open
anyways so my goal going forward with
this channel is to see if i can make it
financially viable uh youtube full time
and that seems a little far off you know
with there just being 188 of us
188 guys it's been three years you would
have thought i would have hung up my hat
at this point 188 subscribers took me
three years to do okay it's context
context okay this was the start
basically of the coffee break era now
some of you know this this was when i
realized that video essays i might be
good at that try it out try a little bit
more of my writing personality my what i
was thinking about
okay this was a really good era for me
this is also when i started editing a
lot more i'll just uh
kind of mute this as we go through this
is a video essay about casey neistat how
he took how he took off
um
on youtube not a bad video i rewatched
it i go ah it kind of
you know editing is a little shoddy but
it's stan it stands up it's fine it's
fine right one of the big secrets to
video essays is you can quickly achieve
high production value because a lot of
the assets
are just
used from other people because you're
just kind of using like some copyright
law fair use to transform content right
so that was very helpful and we entered
a new age
of
youtube so we go ahead and switch to
this like hybrid thing that i did for a
while set up this little set and did
this for a while this was when i
basically investigated scientific fraud
at this uh institution in florida state
that was very interesting now we're
getting much more to the modern era you
can see i've figured out a lot of things
at this point
i got a little custom graphic there
that's very nice i've got a little uh
little presence i've even got some nice
music here let's let's play a little bit
of this number 27 a professor in
criminology sent me an email about the
single biggest scandal that the
criminology field had ever seen i looked
into it partly out of curiosity partly
courtesy but what i found obsessed me
for months alleged fraud anonymous
whistleblowers university cover-ups this
investigation changed the way i think
about science not in the way we discover
truth
but how we uncover lies but before we
get into that let's back up our story
begins with an anonymous email sent to
several scientists who are co-authors on
five papers within criminology and
someone decided to start asking
questions
so much more of the current style of
coffee break you can t or really
coffeezilla too like these like
investigations type things you can see
me kind of a little more catching
catching my wind here you can see some
more development in the editing now
we're introducing me on camera again no
longer are we just like faceless behind
some like somebody else's video we're
starting to use our own assets around
this time i wanted to take it further
and well you know what i don't actually
think that's so important at this point
i kind of i don't know sort of was
finding my way i don't think that i
really care to like talk to people who
are at this point i feel like you can
find your way i want to talk to people
who are here i think this is actually
the hard part this gap between
this and when you actually have people
watching you like
between this and the you know i think i
did like 80 videos before 100
subscribers or 100 videos before 100
subscribers like it was yeah it's just
long just a lot of work for no results
for a very long time
and i want to tell you guys that that's
okay much like uh me singing and i suck
it's just years of sucking basically
that's the way it is uh unfortunately
unless you're some savant unless you're
some genius
that's how it is if you go back to mr
beast's first videos it's the same thing
dude i even went back and checked i was
like what are his first videos like they
suck they're terrible i mean he would
tell you the same thing
it just takes you time
to find your rhythm to find what you
want to be doing to find your style like
now when people see my channel they see
this whole like monstrosity that we
built but they don't understand all the
things that we had to do to get to it so
it might be discouraging for someone who
starts out and they're making terrible
videos and they look at us and they go
wow like he's already got it figured out
whatever no dude it took
years to even like not even to even
realize i was on the wrong track okay
not even to get on the right track so at
this point it's been seven years i've
been on youtube i plan to do it for many
more i love youtube i love creating
videos and i feel like i've really kind
of found my voice found my style but
this message is for those people out
there who have not i know we talk about
scams there's nothing about scams this
is literally about paying the favor
forward for some of you guys out there
who may think to yourself oh i can't do
that i'm not talented i'm not good at it
guys i'm not i'm not this i'm not that
like i don't know how to say
more clearly that if you feel like you
don't know what you're doing if you feel
like you're bad at something if you feel
like you're a beginner that's perfectly
normal that's exactly where you're
supposed to be and if you really want to
do something if you just stick with it
if you just push through it will
eventually pay off for you so i wanted
to send this positive message out there
we don't talk about this a lot we talk
about a lot of scams
but guys there are some underlying
messages that i also want to push
about um you know things like this
creating stuff
doing videos online so i hope this
message was positive for you guys i hope
you enjoyed realizing that um
i spent years being bad at things
i don't know if that helps
anyways i guess i don't really have it
into this video so uh
[Music]
if you enjoyed watching pump the stock
as always thanks a bunch
[Music]
but things will be different if i was
balling